I mean even compared to like Koreans in
Koreatown like we don't have to in a
store yeah of any kind yeah I want to
make the arc that argument what let me
just make the argument yeah
is that because people say that a lot
like you're lucky you know you don't get
to help you don't have a day job and you
don't have to you know work dig holes
but it's like who digs holes I don't
know I don't know what what what a
construction people do they dig holes
but also as Margaret knows and I'm not
I'm just saying that yeah it's as if I
won this job in a lottery mm-hmm you
know I signed up I went through years of
struggling just now I just want to throw
that out there you know I mean but also
I don't do enough of me going I should
just be grateful that I can breathe and
I can see yeah I can hear yeah
you should be grateful for those season
with that we don't have to work in a
piano store in Koreatown that's the
worst that's the worst the piano store
so many piano stores aggressive yeah
they're all the same yeah also a wig
store Oh weeks I was born in a wig store
oh yeah wait what okay yeah my pet I
grew I was born inside literally a wig
store yeah and my my cradle is what they
call them crib and my cradle was in the
mannequin storage room not cream oh my
god ones not creepy right so there was
like 50 like mannequins staring down at
me right and I'm a little baby oh my god
yeah anyway you're scared of white
people scared man scared of George and
Bryce Bryce all the time hello Bobby
I'm intimidated by white people because
of that experience and then I saw did
your parents a violent or arrow story
in that way oh yeah yeah totally but
then they were also pretty busy so they
were more abandoning than they were that
you know because they were never around
because I was always working to be done
one of my generation we never had
babysitter's so I remember just being
alone in the house and I was like five
years old which is so crazy to think
about now yeah it's crazy to think but
now it's just like by myself
oh my god using the stove and [ __ ] he
had the own dough but you had a
boyfriend so they had a gay bookstore
which had porn in it but only gay porn
nostra so it was all gay gay erotic
novels a lot of Tama Finland picture
books and photography books and yeah so
there was a lot of really like confused
my mom liked looking at these it's like
what it's like when Filipinos pointed
things with their limbs the worst one
they said do good boy okay wouldn't we
what is that Hugo boy yoga which means
I'm gonna kill you oh then throw you
away way to throw you away yeah yeah
yeah and as a kid I understood what that
throw you away pose of your body yeah
yeah sure like just kill me throw me
yeah but they want to hide the body so
they don't go to prison because we're
smart yeah uh oh you know what I I
talked about this on a podcast was one
like you your parents your Korean
parents meet like your friend
miss them oh yeah yeah this is Charlie
yeah they don't even wanna lock eyes
yeah and you know you know acknowledge
him as a human being yeah yeah it's so
weird but um so they had that is that
why because you have a huge LGBT is that
what I mean cuz you talked about that in
your heart
yeah and I'm also bisexual so that
there's also that there there's a lot of
that I brought in to which is great
about growing up in the gay community
because I knew where I fit in but also
like my very early material was about
growing up in that gay bookstore and and
and being around that and talking about
gay stuff which in the 90s wasn't really
very popular for comedians you certainly
didn't see a lot of that also seeing an
asian-american woman doing it was so
groundbreaking I mean even for me I went
to go see you you're taping for your
special in the Long Beach Convention
Center oh yeah I think that was in 2008
probably two dozen yeah yes yeah yeah
and listening I had brought my best
friend Jessica with me who had never
seen you do stand it Warren she's a
Korean girl mm-hmm and she left there
and she was never the same like she
thought that she she was allowed to just
[ __ ] just about everybody she's always
kind of been like you know sexually more
like conservative and whatnot and you
see a what an Asian woman talk about it
so freely and it kind of just opens you
up in a different way especially for her
and I be you know just young
20-something Asians we're always told to
kind of be mums the word when it comes
to like your sexuality of course and it
just broke us open like seismically too
but we we came [ __ ] in our 20s you
know it was really nice wonderful I
think that's great I think it's great I
free and to feel good about it mmm you
know because I've had gay experiences
would that make me a bisexual or not
maybe
well if you wanted to continue I don't
want to admit to the ones left on you
know I have no anal you know I mean no I
haven't but I've sucked a lot of pee
pees
but before before all right don't look
at me that way before I would the age of
1213 that doesn't count it doesn't
talked about well he's lying 1718
according to your brother
notice that my brother [ __ ] doesn't
know how could I first of all I was 17
when I got sober the first time and I
stayed sober for 12 years I didn't do
what every time I would have it has no
bearing on my how I feel about you take
as much a dick if you wanna be okay I'm
close your books
[Music]